What I want you to think about is, imagine that we've got a graph with n nodes and m edges,
and we're going to try to find out whether it's colorable well with k colors
by turning it into a big formula like the one I just showed you.
I want to know how many clauses are in the formula, and just to make that a bit more concrete
a clause is the sort of thing that I got here in parenthesis, it's between the n's.
We have a list of things that are combined and then there's an n and then there's more things
that are combined and an n, so how many things are being ended together in the formula.
So I want you to figure out an actual expression in terms of k, n and m that will tell you the answer,
but I'll actually ask you to do it for just a concrete example.
So imagine we've got 3 colors, 8 nodes and 20 edges, how many clauses are in the formula
that result from converting this 3 colorability problem into a satisfiability problem,
and when you have your answer, write it in this box and we'll check it for you.